not every explicit phonics curriculum
uses the same sounds or the same
spelling rules in the same way they're
very similar but not exact so to help
your student not become confused or feel
like they're starting over again we
would recommend that you stay with the
literacy essentials curriculum the
emphasis again is not on memorizing
spelling words so this idea that you
would write your word twenty times in a
row is not something that we would
recommend we would encourage you you to
use the phonograms and the spelling
rules which will provide your student
with the tools to be able to decode read
and write hundreds of words as opposed
to those that they are simply memorizing
so where do these spelling words come
from that you're using they can come
from a couple different places following
every spelling test that your students
did the teacher may have provided you
with a list of those spelling words for
reading practice but these same words
can be used to review and to reap RAC
tiss and to decode and to put into
sentences to analyze to organize you can
do all sorts of things with this list of
words so hopefully your teacher if they
have not provided it to you hopefully
they can do that and it will give you a
nice starting place for the words that
your student has been exposed to and
been working with you might also take
those words from any of the reading
material that your student is reading or
working in that is at their grade level
so choose five to ten spelling words
from one of the books that is at their
level and use those spelling words in a
number of different ways for practice so
the words from the book are becoming the
words that you are practicing they're
becoming your spelling words all right
specific things that you can do with
those spelling words you can create
flashcards to help with the two-way
pronunciation of spelling words so we
say island but when students spell they
would say is land so you could show this
so show them this card say the word is
island what are you gonna think to spell
and they would say is land you could do
same thing with sealer we say sealer but
when we think to spell ask them what do
we say and they should say seal or again
they should say a game and we use this
as an example in the earlier earlier
video we say said but when a student
spells it ask them what are you going to
say to yourself and they should say
Sayed so you can create cards to help
with those two-way pronunciations and
just work through with students another
little idea recommended by literacy
essentials is to create a tiny picture
on a card and the student could even
could even do this so the word Rain uses
the two letter phonogram a I and they
can they can have one drop for the a and
one drop of water for the I and the two
drops will help them remember that that
a sound contains two letters so another
idea of things you could do with a
spelling word if you are working with
homonyms you can create a card and let a
student or they'll have the student
create the cards and draw the tiny
picture to differentiate between the two
and an aunt you can sort the spelling
words that you take from books or from
those lists into a number of different
types of organization in this particular
one its nouns and verbs so as you go
through you can work with your student
to put those words in the correct column
and then you can help them mark and
decode and then have them read back to
you you can also include consonants
opposites compound words suffixes which
are the endings to words those eggs are
and add sounds at the end you could do
phonogram pairs you could create lists
of silent e words you could do synonym
so taking all of those words that are
either on that sheet or the words that
you have chosen from the material that
they are reading and organize them based
on their sounds or their purpose
another idea using the phonogram
patterns this is the sound of EAA and
students are going when they come to
words that have that specific sound and
funny grand in them baking to start
creating lists and putting it in that
list another idea would be to create a
scrambled word list so students are
responsible to unscramble the word and
then decode it decode it or market
decode means to market and then you
would have them read those words to you
you could also use those words in a
dictated sentence when you dictate a
sentence to your student you are telling
them what to write and they are the ones
writing it on the paper so using those
three words that fan scrambled you might
create the sentence that says the clerk
will shine the beautiful mace now when
you do that you can pull in all kinds of
good stuff related to grammar and
complete sentence writing you can remind
them about capitals at the beginning you
can remind them what goes at the end
what kind of end mark does that sentence
get you can talk about the subject who's
that sentence about you can talk about
the predicate what's happening in that
sentence you can find the verbs in that
sentence and go back and put them on
your go back and put them on your noun
and verb sheet you can find the nouns in
that sentence so there are all kinds of
things that you can do with those three
spelling words that you had them
unscramble mark read to you and put in a
sentence for older students they can
create the sentence themself using the
words that are here
I would encourage both you and your
students if they're older in writing
their own sentence that the other words
in the sentence are at the knowledge
level of the student so a second grader
would not use words above their level
in the rest of their sentence and you
would not give them a word that was
beyond what they had learned for their
spelling words if you have a Scrabble
game at home you can pull out your
Scrabble tiles and let children create
words using the letter tiles one idea is
to take the letters of a word and put
them at the top of a table add a few
extra ones mix them all up and then give
students the sounds or phonograms have
them pull the letters down and create
the word for example if the word were
paid you would say pull down the tile
that represents the phonogram they would
find the PE pull it down then you would
give them a - literally that we do not
use at the end of English words they
would find those two letters that create
represent that one sound pull that down
you could give them and they would pull
that down then help them to blend those
sounds and eventually read the word
everything that you're doing if students
are writing or you're showing them
everything should be read back to you
students should be reading their words
and their sentences back to you
you could play guess my word without
using the tiles you could give students
the phonogram sounds and have them write
the word on their paper then go back and
mark or decode the word and then read
the word to you if you have two or more
students at home that could work
together so if you have a kindergartener
in a second-grader and they work well
together you could pair them and let
them do some of these activities
together as opposed to being led by you
as the parent a couple other important
things to think about as you're working
at home it's very tempting to use a
tablet or a computer but students
especially at the lower elementary level
are missing out on the brain connection
between their hand and their mind as
they are writing and the research shows
it is just not there when you're pushing
keys on a tablet so every opportunity
you can provide for a student to
right something it's excellent you can
create your own notebook by stapling
pages together you could buy a spiral
notebook to keep things in you could
even you could even take a brown paper
bag and cut it up into paper size pieces
and use it and it would still be a
better option than to have your student
pushing keys on a tablet part of the
literacy essentials curriculum that
orton-gillingham see it say it here at
Wright it is so important for young
students as they're learning to read and
write so please include that as you're
working with students on home at home so
just to kind of go over some ideas stay
within the curriculum work on the sounds
and not on memorizing think about where
your words are going to come from maybe
from the old an old spelling sheet or
maybe from reading material that the
student has don't forget the importance
of putting pencil to paper it could also
be a dry erase board on a dry erase
marker on a whiteboard another good way
to get them writing and then have
students read everything to you that
they write so all of their sentences
that they've created all of their words
that they've pulled down that they've
unscrambled that they've decoded give
them the opportunity to read out loud to
you I hope you find some of these ideas
helpful as you're working at home and we
are here to answer any questions and to
offer more ideas if you need them thank
you
you